This is the game to decide the winner for the prize money
Hello everyone and welcome back to the coverage of the finals of the Magnus Invitational
We are at Game four and the Nakamura needs a win to get back into the match
He already did it once in game two now. Can he do it once again in Game four?
With the white pieces no less. So again, we have d4 from Hikaru and Knight to f6
And again, we're gonna go into the Queens gambit declined c4 e6 nine of three and d5
The Queens gambit declined is on the board and Knight to c3
So, let's see who's gonna switch it up or are both of them satisfied with the games that we've already played
We have c6 my magnets going for the semi Slav
Bishop to g5 and now Knight B to d7
Now we have a three and now Queen to a5 magnets goes for the Canberra Springs variation
Which I think it's been quite a while since we've seen it on this channel, especially in top-tier tournaments
But okay Knight to d2
Not allowing this night to be pinned. Also preventing the this Knight from jumping to e4. Sorry about that and
We have D captors and C for the main move here is Bishop to b4?
however
Magnus goes for D captures on c4 instead which has been played quite a lot in 2020 and
Nakamura goes for the for the
Obvious choice as now you opened up the attack towards the bishop by capturing and c4
So Bishop captures on f6 Knight captures and only now do you recapture on c4 we have Knight captures on c4
You could also capture with the bishop
But the bishop will be developed e to end the night from c4 attacks
The Queen wall also prevents this Bishop from being developed to d6, which is kind of useful in hindering blacks development
so Queen back to c7 and now Bishop to e2
Nakamura prepares the castle with Bishop to e7 and
a3 now taking away the before square from blacks pieces also preparing before we have castles by Magnus and now
B4 as planned we have looked to d8
Now that makes sense as the Queen is still on the ones who?
White might have to worry about ideas like ePHI which could free the the light square bishop
and adjust castles here now and there is one game where Bishop to d7 was played but here we have b6 by Magnus and it
as of move
13 that we have a completely new game
So Nakamura continues with Bishop to f3 grabs hold of this diagonal prevents Carlson from executing c5
So Bishop, the a6 first attacks the knight here we have Queen to b3
Defending while also connecting rooks and now rotate the ca the rook is now
not on the eighth square anymore, and you are now ready to push c5 we look a to
C1 and now just developing the rook also the queen is on
c7 so it it doesn't make sense and Magnus just pushes c5 as a Hikaru allowed it so
D captures and c5 and here Bishop captures and c4 first Magnus wants to trade as many pieces as possible
Queen captures and B captors in c5 now
and while you could continue just capturing here first Knight to a4 by Hikaru and
Knight to d7 adding another defender to the c5 pawn and here Hikaru is very happy with his position
Obviously problem is Magnus only needs a draw to win the match
So if you go for someone like Queen a6 put pressure on the pawn here
just a nice active move now black is unable to capture due to this then Queen to be 8 is very
Strong and again, if you capture then black is very happy just trading everything character scalpers captures and we have this
Our position where both players have an a pawn
But black has it nicely defended and no problems for black so he car needs a move that keeps the game alive
He tries Queen to b5 instead and the Magnus now
Needs needs to find a move that basically neutralizes all of he carves threats now
25 is one such move that that does so but Magnus instead goes for Queen to b8 and he says
I'm not worried about anything here now
Let's just trade Queens and I will be very happy to hold this end game and he curses. All right
But by doing so I will also grab a pawn
So Queen actress on b8 we have rook after sandy 8 and now just be captures on c5
So not Knight captures and c5 allowing more trades Hikaru keeps some more pieces on the board
But this also means that he keeps the knight on the edge of the board, but he does have an extra pawn
So, let's see
What what can the past see Pandu look D to see it from Magnus and now?
C6 he car starts pushing his passport. We have Knight to e5 now with a double attack on the pawn here
And just rook the c3 by hikari preparing rook F to c1 to double up on the C file
magnus grabs on f3 with check we have G captures in the now King to f8 Magnus starts bringing the King into the game, which
says that he and he also says to Hikaru you cannot bring your knight into the game because I'm just gonna trade and I'm very
Happy with my position
also, you can to do something like the 95 and rook captures and ceases because you have this check which would win the rook but
the Magnus of course would adjust
Capture and then start bringing his King into the game, and he would be very happy
You can double up here and maybe maybe even win the pawn back. So no problems for Magnus
so he karo instead goes rook to d1 and now cutting off the the black King and also preparing a
Beautiful trick Carson goes King to e8 and we have worked the d7 by Hikaru trying to trick Magnus into going rook captures
Here the kind of trade rooks but here he Carl had rook captures on e7 prepared which basically leaves him up a whole night
so Magnus
Of course spots the trick he plays Bishop to f6 gets the bishop out of harm's way with tempo as the rook is under attack
so rook to c5 and only now does Magnus grab the phone we have rook captures rook captures on e7 now by Hikaru and
rook captures on c5 we have Knight captures on c5 and now we have this position where he car is still up upon but it's
a passed a pawn
Which could prove?
Prove to be a bit difficult to defend
so Magnus goes to Buster back to e7 that puts pressure on the knight and Knight to e4 now and
F5 now
we have Knight back to g3 and the g6 now Magnus has to start improving the position of the King and
Keep an eye on that a3 path bone
So a4 Hikaru starts pushing it and King to f7 now. And here we have
92 trying to bring the knight into the game the other way around
King to f6 and now rook to a6 now
It's a question whether you just start pushing the pawn or do you?
Try to create some threats Hikaru goes to rock the a6 for is going for night before to put pressure on the e6 pawn
So rook the b2 by Magnus and now Knight to f4 Magnus even allows this
Sorry, not Knight the d4 Knight to f4 and here just came to f7 not allowing this point to fall with Church
Magnus is basically inviting inviting this capture because if Knight captures here, then you get Bishop to h4
And you go after the f2 pawn then the e3 pawn then well
You're gonna grab a lot of pawns and you will be very happy. So Nakamura ignores this eise exponent
He goes 4/9 to D. Three attacks Carlson's rook
And now rook the a2 cousin just puts a room behind the passed pawn
We have looked at a seven and the King to have sex not allowing the bishop to be pinned and now f4
which is very strong as it prevents the the King from moving so you might
You know, it could be very dangerous
for example
If the bishop moves you can see that the rook is controlling the entire seventh rank and you know
If with the pawns controlling this if the knight gets all the way
Let's say to eat. It could be checkmate, but that's a lot of moves
So Bishop to d6 by Magnus and now rook the a6 is going after the Bishop King
b7 and now Knight to e5 and now this Knight is an extremely strong piece here if
If you don't eliminate it, it's just gonna be there forever. You're not gonna be able to move all your pieces a lot
So Magnus says I am very happy to hold this rook and pawn and game being a pawn down
so Bishop captures
We have F captures and King d7 and now he carrots to find
how to create how to create threats here and how to start the pushing this point of the board
So here you go King to g2 if you try something like rook the a7 check to go after the h7 pawn
Just King c6 and after rook captures here
You're gonna capture this point and you will be very very happy holding this if you go after rook here King d5
You're gonna grab this pawn, and this is all very fine for Magnus
So King g2 akaru not interested in parting with his pawn here
g5 by Magnus
We have looked the d6 check and came back to e7
Hikaru goes back rook to a6 and Magnus says I'm very happy with a draw here as I
In the magic if we draw the game so a5 Hikaru starts pushing the pawn and the magnet starts pushing on the Kings side
We have h5
look back to d6 wait to check and we have a repetition King is 7 but now a
6 so Hikaru got this pawn to a6
But now the question is how do you get it?
Further up the board because Magnus is not moving his rook from behind the passed pawn
so we have age 4 here my Magnus and now rook the rook the b6 just
Trying to create some some threats here rook to b7 check followed by a 7 is an idea so King to d7
And now rook back to d6 check now
If you go for this check, then just kink the c6 and you cannot push the pawn since the rook hangs
So look back the d6 with check King to e7
and now the problem is he coral is already done - one minute and some twenty seconds whereas cousin has I
Think around two and a half minutes
So Hikaru really burning a lot of time trying to figure out how to go about this with h3
and now just rook the a5 by Magnus also puts pressure on the pawn here, of course here and you're not interested in capturing that
So f4 by Hikaru, and now g4 by Magnus and now if you capture here
Then you just give black to connected pass pawns. You don't want to do that
So look back to b6 but now look the a2 with check
We have King the h1 and now rook the a1 with check with King to g2 rook the a2 with check
And here Kings the f1 by Hikaru now Magnus repeats rook to e1 with check King g2
and now look the ATO with check and it was in this position that
the the players agree to a draw as if there is no way to make further progress if he Carl gets greedy and tries to
Go somewhere like this. Then the H point will just Queen
So you don't really have an option you have to repeat moves and just continue getting out of checks
So by drawing this game Magnus wins the match and by this he wins the Magnus cross an invitational tournament
And before we forget here are the final standings after
the tournament ended so Magnus Carlsen wins first place and also the price of
$70,000 followed by he carvings second with
$45,000 then ding lurin in third and Fabiano in fourth now sharing 30,000
I thought it would be it'd be a bigger price for third and fourth, but since
I it was a knock out and they bought we were eliminated in the semifinals
It doesn't make sense that it's equal
Then in 50 on the pony issue with 22 and a half then ali reza fuchsia with 20
onigiri with 17 and a half and a maxi marshal a graph in eighth place with
$15,000 so that that sums up to total prize fund of twenty two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
Which still makes it the big biggest ever online chess event in chess history of the world
Yeah, that's the game. I do. Hope you enjoyed it and that you enjoyed my short coverage of this event
Probably probably going to return to the poem or fish taco
We're gonna check up on wheel watch s0 and well pretty much everything else that's happening and it's just roll
We have the nation's Cup coming up
So we're gonna check that out as well, but I might take a day or two off to you know
Relax a bit now after this event has finished
Nobody on and this is the third time Magnus defeats
Hikaru Nakamura in D in the online
Online finals of some first thing he beat him in twenty sixteen speeches championship
Then I believe in 2018. Speech Chess Championship
And now in 2020 the the Magnus Invitational so tough break for Hikaru, but there is always next time
Yeah, once again, I do. Hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Neil's wild called Nilsson Blair Barnes a Bryce Foster and the Donald Kinsey for a contribution to my channel
Thank you a lot. I really appreciate it as usual. You can check two of my previous videos here
Thank you for watching and I will see you soon. Continuing
Whatever. I feel like continuing most likely about yeah, thank you. All I will see soon and have an excellent rest of your Sunday